you can get our podcast on podcast one
or clicking the podcast link on our on
our app every single day and the podcast
called 100% honest pretty much on
podcast one right there the host of that
along with a member of battle of the
Network Stars on the team coached by our
previous guest DeMarcus Ware good to see
you Tom Arnold great see buddy how are
you sorry about doing well how you doing
I'm doing better for you sitting next to
me she's great guys she's great
oh yeah she's right yeah you're so lucky
you know I'll tell you what I am a lucky
man hey you are three kids and a wife
and you know where you can come in here
and as I mentioned in the television
audience I was looking for the period on
this best damn sports show yeah well
here you are no we got a I'd like to do
another show like that you know now that
it's a real Network and one of my
segment producers is the president of
Fox Sports now Eric shanks Eric shanks
was a segment producer on best damn
sports show Aris yes now he runs the
joint
yes he does yeah so you can so let's
let's do what write best and if we're
rebooting Battle Network Stars by the
way wait when I was a kid battles
Network started with a great show and B
my dad used to watch it we loved it so
for me to grow up and be on battle of
the Network Stars yes you know it's a
little different though because I
thought my dream was I'd be on a show
with Bruce Jenner and OJ Simpson that
we'd be competing but uh yeah now it's
2017 yeah it's tomorrow Connor well I
mean it make that down well and so what
what network I was going to ask you what
network you represent by ABC because
I've had the most canceled shows maybe
seeing so but there's 20 teams which I
guess means you know in this in this
world there's no logic to this show
writable are you kidding me a lot of
people said no and then these people
said yes that's how it was
that's that's absolutely out wet and so
you said yes yes I did okay because I'm
looking by the way you want you want to
let's go stroll down memory lane right
here's the battle I pulled up the Battle
of the Network Stars roster from 1977 Oh
40 years ago yeah okay so you're on
battle network stars 2017 right ready
for this Brockman yet a la 2017 s Battle
Network Stars Tom Arnold what's run
through the 1977 joke a ABC team since
you're right technically I was a senior
in high school Hummel high 77 Hummel I
was yet Hawaii where radar O'Reilly was
from LA he's a fake cake person from Mac
a real person hey go forth because
you're yeah you're technically on on
Team TV sitcom yes that's you yeah and
you were going against on the pre
remember premiere episode tomorrow night
TV kids right you're you're going
against Joey launch Kim fields of facts
alive by the way don't underestimate her
she has a low center of gravity
I know I mean that in a good way like if
she's in front of a tug of war you could
have a hard time pulling her into the
bud pit let me tell you and I mean that
is a huge couple but she's great I loved
her okay here we go
ears ears team ABC from 1977 okay you
win Howard Coker they still be not to
tell who is okay team able we didn't
lose all right Tom periods are real
people the ABC team captain was as I
joked with DeMarcus Ware it was Gabe cap
yeah yeah yes from welcome back on us at
a great game Laura Burton oh my gosh for
Rhodes video the reading thing Richard
Hatch in Battlestar Galactica oh my gosh
Ron Howard who was on hospice or the
time man's day one of the greatest
directors of our time yeah Kristy
McNichol oh my gosh she's a lesbian
should I say baby that would be when I
would go at first all top actress back
in 1977 she was uh she was part of what
was he part of uh what's your honor
eight is enough I remember her they
McNichols your shoes on The Love Boat
yes yes
like I said you go in first how Linden
Barney Miller guys I love halogen play
cards with him Jaclyn Smith aware so
Charlie's enjoy yeah mess hey now Penny
Marshall from a burning Charlie any she
still what you have good Fred he sound
like legit stuff I was like bro Penny
Marshall director correct yes people
these people caught on to great things
yes so I can't imagine pay Marshall Duty
is a bit physical I guess you did did
she spend then I'm not during that time
probably also lied yeah smoke break in
between the dead of war and the Rope the
Rope she kept and Laverne and Shirley
open and yeah I was just joking I did
not see this list she'd be a good anchor
though whatever they was talking about
an hour's hour to with DeMarcus worse
Telly Savalas was it was ABC oh my gosh
he must have lost money gambling the
team captain of NBC was Robert Conrad
Reiner was in this oh my honey Bono I
mean I could keep going on and on here
but but but obviously you did you won't
because is not health care actually it
doesn't well they won the other name is
cool
I mean Kurt Russell James seemed
Restless have you just started with your
Russell I what if he got here to the
number one yes right right game Haggerty
I don't know that is it was a mountain
man yes he was on a grizzly out or is he
Adam seekers Adams been at at Russell
right well anyway oh yeah how was it Tom
I mean get up to Jeff to limber up did
you have no idea I slept all the way
there in Bangka car I woke up about
after I've been there for four or five
hours according to DeMarcus
yes and it uh it was go time you know I
know when it's time to go yeah I'm in
show business I don't have to come there
ready to go or in the business yeah you
know it was it was fine but it did get
competitive I have to say that I did
want to win and I didn't think I thought
I would think it was stupid because I
were competing against you know celeb
celebrities and they're they suck
generally right
there's like real athletes that are
celebrity athlete well and plus nobody
wants to let bronson pinchot down by the
way when it comes to it thicker than you
remember his hair is darker than you
remember but he has guts and he will try
anything he'll do the obstacle course
even if he ends up in the water he will
try anything he's an effective okay I
did think I mean by the way that was not
meant as any disrespect otherwise I
don't feel it oh how about this I love
your hair okay
I don't disrespect no disrespect I do
have the best haircut that I've had in a
long time you look good you look good
thank you guys thank you so you know a
transplant since I've seen you I could
they get it right here doubt see so they
used to just use the top yeah now they
get them here so it looks more natural
oh my gosh Tom Arnold here on the Rich
Eisen show the Battle of Network Stars
premiering at 9:00 Eastern time tomorrow
night on ABC what was I sure I'm sure
they get it they got real giant stars
coming on right look and again I just
read from 1977 so 2007 is over a
greenberg yeah is it Eddie where's the
same coat that the old house were that
the Cosell war he wide wide world of
sports yes he doesn't fit him he looks
really stupid in it it's a same color
and so they got that gold I find it hard
to believe that mike Greenberg would not
be wearing something that's finely
tailored I cannot imagine I could watch
for yourself that I will do that and
then the gun shows on afterwards they
have tried to remake a gun show I bet
the time I watched it with my kids last
week and it was phenomenal my gentle
know the the rebooted one oh my gosh
yeah yeah the look on my six-year-old
space when you watch somebody in a
Little Bo Peep costume put it tarantula
in her mouth and play a harmonica
yes was something I will never fail but
you see does dad do that you know Jamie
Fox shows a game show doubt that's right
face probably bald what does it that's
right strand
it's your god stray head yes your guy
struggle do anything let's be honest
anything when was the last time you
spoke to Arnold Schwarzenegger two weeks
ago we did a at school all-stars event
at his house okay and he
well I try to think what I what not to
say he apologized for a core say that he
didn't think Donald Trump would would
slap him on the apprentice yeah and and
then Donald Trump slapped him on the
oppressor he did and he apologized well
who's gonna slap Comey I mean that's
true you know it's true you don't know
just be you don't of it yeah yeah you
could resist no Arnold's do great okay
man that's good which you could be
President if only you're born in this
country that's you know we call that a
road block right right well then there's
other personal issues that may come up
yeah you know there's a company well you
don't do a Roseanne jokes a bore let's
put it that way
you know first of all I don't know
anyway
Jesus that what is up they're supposed
to and then I was like dude what about
apparently you'd have sex with the couch
okay anyway up but deadbolt this will be
in the show right no it's lunch okay
good you know they're rebooting Roseanne
fine I heard the art and I'd like to
reboot or to you know just square with
the weighted it for so weighted by car
so I think that's great as they are
great actors I love working with them I
wish of the best what a great idea
so that means you haven't been called to
be probably happened but I was called
the last minute to do a roast after
everybody else said oh so what I will do
that look at what roseburg Comedy
Central Roast
I did I did it I tried I was very
nervous but I did it did anybody see it
I must have missed that one but it was a
big it was real and I did it and you
know I respect her I appreciate her and
I wish her the best luck and Laurie
Metcalf is one of the best actions of
the country John Goodman you know all
those people
good luck hmm you know Willa grace is
back too by the way
that's right yeah I know that did you
hear called for that I did I did max
what's it called aid for that so I got a
better chance to be on that that
Roseanne Highway should block it'll be a
great show still be great it's you know
so are they really rebooting best damn
sports show or did your you're just
throwing that out there
no no no I want that physically burly
Fox Sports one is rebooting ESPN's
Dover's right now no offense to my
friend Eric shanks but apparently
whatever does it they're taking over
yeah they givin up on be original
because I was about to say that you
can't reboot a show it's the best damn
sports show period because when they say
period I mean that's the end of this
right you don't even keep that in sure
what so the I guess that would be best
damn sports your exclamation point right
you'd have to upgrade the punctuation
right yeah I mean not to get too deep in
the weeds here well you are way too deep
in the wind
yeah I don't know I just like to do a
sports show cuz I love sports and I
would do it for free
hmm well I would do it for free but it
was a great honor one of the best jobs
I've ever had maybe the best I got to
beat my idols my heroes I didn't have to
be objective because I just was a fan
and I loved it well I can't wait I got
to see John Salley you know by the way
final stereotypes are true
that's the grill desire Sal oh my gosh
it had an elbow that's all going to tell
you okay Tom you're the best please come
back thank you I'm all ready okay same
here you literally are the best you
literally are the best thank you that
that's my publicist and I'm eat it you
are the best thank you Tom arm I mean so
please do come back and thank you now
that your that's sincere that sense that
I made that of course although a couple
times you fixed your glasses on your
face with your middle finger a couple
times under this conversational yeah I
hit it so big my glasses don't fit I
have a size 8 head all right Rosie -
thank you Tom Arnold thank you so much
check out battle the Network Stars
tomorrow night at 9:00 Eastern Time the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to